no
questo è l'antartide abbiamo passato qui
a un anno e per nove mesi
siamo rimasti fisicamente isolati dal
resto del mondo vivendo con altre 11
persone presso la stazione di ricerca
italo francese concordia e nonostante
tutto se parliamo ancora anzi abbiamo
deciso di fare un teddy insieme perché
vorremmo raccontarvi di come questa
esperienza abbia sfidato è cambiato il
nostro punto di vista sulle relazioni
umane e ci abbia dato un'idea di come
sia possibile vivere anche in condizioni
al limite con persone che sembrerebbero
impossibile magari qualcuno di voi starà
pensando al suo ufficio oppure alla
suocera chissà ma dove siamo finiti
esattamente la base gestita
congiuntamente dal programma nazionale
di ricerche in antartide dall'istituto
polare francese si trova ad homs nel
mezzo dell'altopiano orientale antartico
a 1.200 chilometri dalla costa e oltre
3.000 metri sul livello del mare la
temperatura che d'estate non sale mai al
di sopra dei meno 30 gradi centigradi
può scendere
durante l'inverno al di sotto dei meno
80 e se ci mettete anche l'effetto del
vento ovvero considerate quella
percepita potete persino arrivare fino
alle tre cifre sotto lo zero è un
deserto freddo e inospitale più secco
addirittura del sarà niente acqua
liquida niente montagna niente
vegetazione
niente città chiaramente né altri
insediamenti umani
nessuna forma di vita a parte voi stessi
perché andare fino alla giu ricerca
scientifica e d'altronde dove altro ho
trovato il laboratorio all'aperto piatto
stabile senza influenze umane lungo
1.200 chilometri o una calotta di
ghiaccio spesso a più di 3.000 metri che
contiene al suo interno come vedremo gli
ultimi 800 mila anni di storia climatica
del pianeta
laggiù c'erano una cosa facile e una
difficile quella facile anche se magari
non ci crederete era proprio il freddo
ora il 10 agosto 2015
la data prescelta per il consueto snow
pitt mensile questo non è nient'altro
che una buca nel ghiaccio di un metro di
profondità che dobbiamo scavare a mano
per poter misurare i profili di
temperatura e densità della neve ora
queste misure servono anche per definire
una scala del tempo la più precisa
possibile per la carota epica che cos'è
la carota etica si tratta di un carotone
di ghiaccio lungo 3.270 metri frutto di
un progetto europeo che si chiama punto
epica ora analizzando le bolle d aria
fossile sigillate nel ghiaccio e gli
isotopi dell'ossigeno e dell'idrogeno
contenuti nelle molecole di acqua
siamo riusciti a ricostruire il clima
del pianeta pensate degli ultimi 800
mila anni
a dom sì le precipitazioni sono
pochissime e questo ha fatto sì che si è
accumulata in quasi un milione di anni
una stratificazione di circa tre
chilometri di ghiaccio
questa per noi è come una sorta di
macchina del tempo se volete che ci
permette di riportare alla luce il clima
del passato almeno in termini di
temperature concentrazioni di gas serra
ma torniamo adesso allo snow pitt sono
le due del pomeriggio e fuori è buio
pesto
come da tre mesi a questa parte come
potete vedere la temperatura di meno 81
gradi centigradi e per fortuna c'è poco
vento solo meno 94 quella percepita
caldo è ci vestiamo come si suol dire a
cipolla allora cominciamo tre strati di
file due paia di calzettoni tre paia di
guanti e poi ancora un berretto un
passamontagna una maschera facciale che
ci consentiranno di respirare l'aria
caustica che troveremo all'esterno ma
non è finita paio di occhiali in tutto
un intero in più ma dei grossi scarponi
bianchi e poi ancora una lampada
frontale uno zaino così vestiti pesiamo
10 kg qui del normale
altro che cura dimagrante
a questo punto si tratta di avvertire lo
stesso un leader via radio e di
informarlo che siamo diretti verso le
scelte della solo jia che cos'è uno
shelter 1 scelta e un container che si
trova a circa un km dalla base e alla
funzione di laboratorio remoto e rifugio
apriamo un portellone che ci isola
dall'ambiente esterno e scendiamo una
scala che ci porta sulla superficie
nevosa del plateau pensate 100 gr di più
in basso
lì camminiamo sul sentiero che ha
illuminato dalla sola luce delle nostre
pile frontali ed ogni volta che speriamo
siamo avvolti da una nube bianca di
minuscoli cristalli di ghiaccio
il vento è debole ma punge e sferza
ugualmente quelle poche parti di pelle
che rimangono esposte il respiro poi tra
l'altro e affannoso perché a 3200 metri
e l'aria e povera di ossigeno e per di
più eppure estremamente secca ora
sebbene questo ci fa sopportare meglio
il freddo provoca anche delle fastidiose
e dolorose ferite sui talloni sulle dita
delle mani
per non parlare del sangue dal naso che
ci cola al mattino al risveglio oppure
delle fastidiose scosse elettrostatiche
che prendiamo ogni volta che tocchiamo
delle parti metalliche giunti allo
shelter
finalmente possiamo entrare a
riscaldarci recuperiamo le ultime
attrezzature e usciamo per un altro
chilometro a piedi verso una pallina si
tratta di un paletto proprio nella
cosiddetta plenaria questa è nient'altro
che una zona incontaminata che è stata
prescelta per lo scavo della buca lì a
turno rimuoviamo dei blocchi di neve
compatta a volte dobbiamo addirittura
usare una sega
altre volte invece si tratta di neve
farinosa inconsistente
dopo circa mezz'ora di lavoro alla buca
è pronta
giampietro c entra come vedete posiziona
il termometro e comincia ad estrarre
ogni dieci centimetri delle carote di
ghiaccio che io raccolgo in appositi
sacchetti risponde in una slitta dopo
aver annotato ovviamente la temperatura
dello strato sul quaderno dei dati
gradualmente le nostre vieta
mani dei piedi perdono sensibilità i
denti cominciano a battere è il corpo
comincia a essere percorso da dei
brividi molto intensi quasi come quelli
che sto provando adesso davanti a voi
quasi dico giampietro di fare in fretta
perché le poche parti di pelle esposta
che riesco a vedere stanno diventando
troppo bianche dovete sapere che la
julie i congelamenti l'ipotermia sono
tra i pericoli maggiori e non è
assolutamente il caso di fare gli eroi
allora chiudiamo in fretta la buca e
trainando la slitta diciamo dirigiamo a
passo svelto verso lo shelter dove
potremo riscaldarci e ben otto gravi
pensate un po
non sentiamo siamo siamo sostanzialmente
a volte da un silenzio surreale rotto
solamente dai nostri passi sulla neve è
sopra di noi c'è un cielo stellato
mozzafiato talmente mozzafiato che a
volte agglomerati di stelle
all'orizzonte ci fanno fantasticare
sull'esistenza di un paese vicino ma
sappiamo di essere soli ed è solo
un'illusione finalmente raggiungiamo lo
shelter e il nostro viso ha ridotto così
lì poco dopo sopraggiunge nelle dita il
classico dolore lancinante di quando si
riattiva la circolazione mangiamo del
della frutta secca sostanzialmente
viviamo un po di te caldo cercando di
recuperare un po di quelle 4 mila
chilocalorie che ogni giorno bruciamo
per affrontare il freddo e la quota io
quasi quasi me lo consiglio se volete
buttare giù qualche chilo di troppo
vi assicuro che funziona
e poi come vi dicevamo c'era una cosa
ancora più difficile
superata la sfida materiale ed un
ambiente totalmente ostile
resta infatti quella più grande alla
costruzione di una comunità in grado di
sopravvivere a un isolamento così lungo
e profondo ed è questo aspetto in
particolare che accomuna concordia alle
missioni spaziali di lunga durata
non a caso l'agenzia spaziale europea
che durante l'inverno gestisce un
programma sperimentale sull'adattamento
dell'equipaggio definisce così marte
bianco il luogo che simile a un pianeta
alieno che voi possiate trovare sulla
terra ogni singolo elemento in comune
tra concordia e un'ipotetica missione su
marte è però anche un potentissimo
elemento di stress
c'è un ambiente ostile come abbiamo
appena visto e le risorse sono
chiaramente limitate
questo significa che dopo un paio di
mesi frutta e verdura fresca scompaiono
dalla vostra tavola e potreste
ritrovarvi a imparare strumentazione con
pezzi di cartone o stagnola il
confinamento l'isolamento stesso ci
tagliano fuori della nostra vita sociale
e affettiva sappiamo che per nove mesi
le condizioni saranno così proibitive
non consentire a nessuno né di andare né
divenire per dargli un termine di
paragone gli astronauti della stazione
spaziale internazionale
possono invece essere evacuati in circa
24 ore
non c'è sole non abbiamo solo per 105
giorni di fila
l'alterazione del nostro orologio
circadiano è forte capita di non
riuscire a prendere sonno di dormire
fino a tardi
oppure ancora più strano risvegliarsi
dopo un paio dovrei completamente
riposati e poi crollare a metà giornata
gli stimoli sono veramente pochissimi
ogni giorno sembra uguale al precedente
viviamo in una tale condizione di
monotonia e deprivazione sensoriale che
persino il tempo libero rischia di
diventare una minaccia gli spazi
personali la nostra privacy sono
fortemente limitate dalle dalle
dimensioni stesse della base
insomma non si riesce a stare da soli
se non chiudendosi nella propria
stanzetta oppure uscendo fuori godersi
il freddo e poi infine il numero
noi siamo soltanto tredici diversi per
età lingua cultura carattere però
necessariamente dipendenti l'uno
dall'altro
e qui la filiera è assolutamente
cortissima se usi un prodotto vietato
basta uno shampoo che rovina l'impianto
di riciclaggio dell'acqua
l'idraulico che ha dovuto ripulire tutto
non mancherà giustamente di farselo
notare a cena
la tensione sale inevitabilmente diventa
difficile gestire le emozioni e dopo un
po all'equipaggio si divide in
sottogruppi spesso in contrasto tra loro
su questione che nella vostra vita
normale giudichereste del tutto
irrilevanti però siamo poi davvero così
diversi dall'equipaggio di un normale
ufficio probabilmente come dicevo
nell'introduzione anche voi avete
qualche collega che non supportate
proprio magari solo perché parla in
continuazione al telefono ad alta voce
vi si rivolge con tono un po arrogante o
magari se ne stà sulle sue sembra
proprio che vi ignari serie sempre ora
quello che cambia qui l intensità perché
voi dall'ufficio tornata a casa una sera
novità concordia usiamo solo dopo nove
mesi almeno nel caso nostro sono state
12 alla fine la sensibilità si acuisce e
piccole cose diventano problemi seri
tenetevi di lorenzo qui sembra simpatico
vero
forse no mi vedete voi un anno poi vi
raccontate noi due abbiamo lavorato
spessissimo insieme e condiviso persino
l'ufficio ogni tanto
l'atmosfera diventava un po rovente come
potrete immaginare una volta era lì che
cercava di risolvere un problema
informatico anch'io però un po di fretta
e lo aspettavo per uscire dalla base ma
quando l'ho chiamato ha cominciato ad
accennare nella faccenda per cui mi sono
seduto per cercare di dare una mano
due minuti dopo ci si urlava addosso che
succedeva in realtà niente di
particolare a patto di essere disposti
ad ignorare completamente le reazioni e
i toni gli serviva soltanto dell'altro
tempo non nell'aiuto dove invece avevo
capito io quindi stavo facendo la figura
del presuntuoso che pretende di
risolvere tutti non secondo la faccenda
aveva irritato giusto un secondo ora
incomprensioni come queste non solo i
germi di con pensioni come queste a
concordi ne abbiamo avute parecchie e
nonostante nessuno dei due sia uno
psicologo
alla fine qualcosa di rilevante per
tutti pensiamo pensiamo di averla
imparata nelle situazioni di convivenza
forzata è molto più importante guardare
direttamente al problema in sé piuttosto
che la persona che lo pone una causa
ignorando tanto i toni quanto
soprattutto le responsabilità perché
questo permette a tutti di sopravvivere
a tanti errori possibili portarne se c'è
l'eventuale peso e soprattutto
collaborare con tutti gli altri alla
loro risoluzione senza perder tempo le
strategie di attacco e difesa in
situazioni come queste alla fine piccoli
gesti attenzione e aperture possono
davvero fare la differenza e impedire
che le vostre relazioni si deteriorino
irreparabilmente
ma più in generale alla fine comandata
beh grazie questi piccoli accorgimenti
ma fondamentali abbiamo avuto anche
lunghi mesi che abbiamo passato
concordia non sono stati solo un incubo
come potreste pensare come vedete
abbiamo avuto anche dei momenti
indimenticabili goliardici addirittura
come una serata una cena con delitto a
tema alice nel paese delle meraviglie o
un evasivo scenario da pirati dei
caraibi
durante la festa di mezza inverno oppure
se preferite ancora una partita del
torneo di freccette contro la base
americana al polo sud
ovviamente in teleconferenza è ora noi a
concordia pensiamo di aver imparato
anche un'altra cosa che vorremmo
condividere con voi qui oggi ognuno di
noi a concordia come nella vita di tutti
i giorni
conosce se stesso attraverso l'altro
diciamo affronta angosce problemi e
sfide collaborando in relazione con gli
altri
noi questo l'abbiamo capito proprio
laggiù per che l'internauta vivessi in
un eremo isolato e confinato ma deve
essere l'esatto opposto di un eremita
per poterne esorcizzare superare le
difficoltà e le avversità a concordia
ognuno di noi da solo non vale nulla o
la propria individualità si costruisce
contestualmente a quella di tutti gli
altri
oppure semplicemente non è tornati dall
antartide abbiamo invece avuto la netta
impressione di essere stati catapultati
in uno strano disarmonico coro composto
esclusivamente da solisti
ci chiediamo allora se la quotidiana
corsa contro una giornata sempre più
corta
la ricerca delle diciamo della
produttività e della continua
affermazione personale non abbiano in un
certo senso messo in secondo piano
l'importanza delle relazioni umane e
della collaborazione tra i singoli
sembrerà un paradosso ma vivere per un
anno in uno dei luoghi più isolati e
remoti del pianeta ci ha scottato in
relazione e ci ha curato con la
collaborazione riportando la nostra
attenzione un po meno su noi stessi e
sull'idea di un'illusoria indipendenza è
un po di più verso gli altri e sulla via
di una sana arricchente interdipendenza
in cui l'essere umano e la relazione
riacquistino un valore al di là
della loro opportunistica utilità sapete
newton diceva che gli uomini
costruiscono troppi muri e mai
abbastanza ponti speriamo di poter
cominciare assieme a dimostrare che
forse si sbagliava
grazie